Hey what's going on guys it's Rob I hope
you had a wonderful holiday season and a
happy new year
If you didn't get that toy that you really
wanted for the holidays
I'm gonna show you how to make something
really cool today..The Origami
Boomerang! This is definitely one of my
most favorite origami models to make
now, it's pretty simple
it's fun for all ages
and it will keep you busy for hours
When I first made it, I was playing around
with it for over an hour
Well, the first why made didn't come out so
good.. Neatness
really counts with this model so you need to be as neat as possible if you want it to
fly well
What you're going to need is a piece of A4 printer paper, or just a basic
8.5" X 11" sheet (Letter Sized) just
like this. You don't want to use cover paper
that's too thick, you don't want to use
construction paper.. just use a sheet like this
and the good thing about it is that
we're going to split it in half
meaning you get to make two Origami
boomerangs
with one sheet. Now, you're probably
wondering how well can
Origami Boomerang really fly that's made
from a piece of printer paper
Well, before we start I'm gonna show you a
quick little video of me throwing it!
You can try throwing two at the same time
To start off, position your printer paper so
that the longer ends are horizontal
then we're going to take the top end of
the paper and fold it down to the
bottom end
and try to be as neat as possible and
align it edge to edge perfectly
When you do so, then you can make a
crease along the top of the paper
and then to split it in half
you can run your fingernail against the
edge.. if you wanna fold it back on itself
do the same the other way you can do
that and then we can split the paper in half
We're going to once again fold the paper
in half lengthwise, so take the top end
of the paper
and fold it down to the bottom end of the
paper to make sure that the edges are
aligned perfectly (as best you can)
and then you can make a crease along
the top up the paper
You may want to just run your fingernail
against it so that we have really good
creases
since that'll help the boomerang fly a
little better. When you unfold the paper
you'll notice we have
a line that divides the paper in half
and we're going to be taking the top
end of the paper and the bottom end of
the paper and folding directly next to
the line you don't want to fold it
right on top of it because when we
follow the boomerang in half again it
might interfere with the edges
So, take the top end of the paper...
Fold it down
next to that line leave a little bit of
space, maybe a millimeter or so
and then you wanna make
a nice crease along the top edge of
the paper
So, as you'll see
I left a little bit of space in between
the middle of the paper and the edge of
the paper there
Do the same for the bottom edge so just
fold it
directly next to that line leaving a
little bit of space
and then we can make the crease
along the bottom up the paper. So as
you'll see
there is a little bit a space in between
the two edges
set when we fold in half it doesn't
interfere
with those edges which we just folded in.
Alright so now we can take
one end of the paper and we're going to
fold it across to the other end
and as you'll see the paper is very
straight so once you align it
edge to edge
just hold it there, and you might need to just pull
on this a little bit to kind of round it off
and it'll allow you to make that nice
crease on the end there
and then you could run your fingernail
over it and then we're going to take
both of the corners here
and we're going to fold them inwards so
that the top edge is aligned with that
vertical line you see
and you may want to just hold the bottom
here because when you fold this
inwards it'll kind of misalign the
paper
so you just wanna hold the bottom here
fold the corner inwards just like that
and make a crease
run your fingernail over it.. do the same
with the left side
just fold that corner in just like that
and make another crease. Then you can run
your fingernail over there
Then you can unfold
both of the corners and we can just fold
it backwards, if you want to flip the
model over
and fold it that way it's fine. Just
fold it backwards on the same crease
which we just made
and run your finger now over it, do the
same
the left side and
run your fingernail over it and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
open the side here
and we're going to tuck both of these
corners inwards
just like that.  So take it, tuck
the corner in
and then just re-close the flaps
Do the same with the left side.
Open it up, tuck the corner in
and then you could just close both of the
edges together
again. Make good creases...
and you're ready to move on. OK, at this
point I need you guys to pay
really close attention, and to listen
carefully since the folding does get a
little tricky here but I'm going to go
through in a lot of detail to make it as
simple for you as I can.
We're going to take the model and we're
going to unfold it.
Then we're going to unfold this
edge on the right that we previously
folded in towards the center. So
unfold the right side of the model
just like that now you'll see we have a
diamond shape
on the right side here so to make this
next told a little bit easier, we're just
going to make some of these creases here
in the diamond a little better. On this
horizontal fold
you want to just take both ends of the
model and to just fold them away from you
and then you want to just run your
fingernail against that horizontal fold
and that's known as a mountain fault since
it creates what looks like a mountain
Then on the outside the diamond here
we also need to just make those creases a
little better
so we're just going to flip over the model
and as you'll see we have the four
creases here
just take your finger and you want to
run your fingernail against the edge
there, so just fold downwards on that
and just run your fingernail against it
and do that with all 4 of
the creases there
so it should look something like that
now just a little bit better
folded. Now you can flip the model over
and now what we're going to do is basically make
a little pocket here so what we want to
do.
is you want to take our thumb and just
close the top
half of the model so that this edge is once
again on the midline
and hold it there and then we're going
to take this diamond and we're going to
squash it
just like that
so you wanna take your thumb and
going to squash this diamond so that
this corner here is folded up
against this piece in the paper here
take it and just flatten it there
against the paper
Then we're going to once again
fold this edge
back inwards toward the midline.  As you'll see, we
have a pocket here
so this corner is going to be right in
that pocket
So just fold it into the pocket
and as you'll see the edge once again
lines up and we have created what looks
like
a pocket here
So once you have a model like this,
you're ready to move on
Okay, so take a model now and on the
corner here
Just make sure that this
crease is sharp, so just fold it downwards
like that and run your fingernail
against it
then we're going to take the left side
of the model and just fold this
edge down
and when you do that this little pocket
area should kinda
form a little mountain there then you're
going to take
that top edge and you're also going to
fold it down so that
this top edge here is on the bottom with
this edge
so fold it down like that and as you'll
see that little
mountain area is going to be folded to
the left now
and form a little pocket in there
Then you could just flatten everything
out
Now, we're just
going to reopen everything
and you're going to lift up this edge here
so that you bring this corner
that we previously tucked
in, and just lift that up
like that
and we're
going to once again
fold this left side down
and then fold the top down and when
we do that
it will once again form that little
pocket in there but we want to have
this corner tucked into that area now
where that pocket has formed. So just
put that in there, close the top down
and just work that corner back into
that area
and make sure everything is folded
nicely
and make a really good creases
So your model should look something like this now
We are pretty much done with
making the Origami Boomerang, we just
need to lock the ends and to do that
we're just going to
open the end like that, and fold
both these corners
in so that the edge here is aligned with
the vertical edge
Fold it in and try to be as neat as
possible and make a crease and run your
fingernail against it
Do the same with the left side
and then you could unfold the one on the
right and you're going to open
the edge like this and tuck this corner
in, similar to like we did before
Just tuck that corner in
As you'll see, it forms a little flap here so
just flatten it out
You can now open the left side and you
have a little flap here now
and then we could re-close the model
so put that
edge back down and as you'll see we have a flap here and you have what
looks like a little pocket formed
by the other flap..
So you could tuck this flap into that
pocket
all the way up to the
crease that we made there, so just
tuck it in like that
and just flatten everything out
You can do the same with the other side
On the left side here we only have one
layer, whereas the other side we had
two layers on both sides, but it works
the same way
So just fold this in, and make a crease
and fold the right side and make another
crease
Then you can unfold the right side, open
this edge..
Tuck this corner and you may need to fold it here on that crease
open this flap, close the model
and then you could finally open that little
pocket there
and tuck that flap in.
Alright guys, so once you've done all
that, flatten everything out
and you have finished your Origami
Boomerang!! Okay, so before you start just
make sure that the model is really neat,
just like this one is here and make sure
all the creases
are very good and the model is flat. If
you do bend
the boomerang, it's not going to fly
correctly.. so it is pretty fragile
but it will endure being hit against walls
and stuff like that but
if it hits a wall it may not going to come
back to you. So hold it like this
with the
line here, the diagonal line, should be
facing upwards
so you don't wanna hold it with this I
little
a flap here on the back.  It should be held
like this
and as you'll see this end here is
diagonally
down to the right like that
so this is the way you wanna throw it
there is a way to make this
I so that you could throw it with your
left hand I know there's some lefties
out there
me included but I am able to throw this
with my right hand
So, once your position at like this you
want to rotate it like a frisbee and
it's going to be thrown
so that the model is spinning clockwise, just throw it like that.. I probably
won't catch you right now but
Let me try to throw it
Well, there you go! So just make sure your model is neat
if it's not coming back to you need to
practice on how to throw it
Make sure the model is very flat and
have fun with your Origami boomerang! Alright guys, thanks for watching.. be sure to
SUBSCRIBE for
further notification of my videos! (Subtitles by Rob's World)